my opponent tonight is activist
Christian peach aleni
his book is called white American youth
my descent into America's most violent
hate movement and how I got out
Christian peach' leading everybody
Christian I would've jump right into
this she used to be a skinhead
that's correct and then you stopped what
walk me through that change of opinion
but also how you got into that world to
begin with you know growing up I was a
pretty marginalized kid I didn't have a
lot of friends and I was bullied and I
didn't really know what my identity or
what my community was and I spent 14
years struggling with where I belonged
and one day at 14 years old I was
standing in an alley smoking a joint and
a man came up to me and he pulled the
joint from my mouth and he looked me in
the eyes and he said that's what the
Communists and the Jews want you to do
they keep you docile and that for me was
really the first time that I felt
acceptance from anybody so you find
yourself in this world kind of thrust
into this world and then and then you
found your way out of that what was that
process well I spent eight years
involved in America's first neo-nazi
skinhead group and I had doubts every
every day for those eight years because
I wasn't raised the racist
I learned it for acceptance what does
that mean you weren't raised but you
learned it like where do you learn that
from so I learned that being a part of
this skinhead group and it didn't start
out as hateful at first and started out
with playing on my feelings of pride of
being Italian of being European and then
eventually as time went on they would
find somebody to blame for taking that
pride away from me and they would blame
everybody from Jews to gays to blacks
and I believed it because I wanted to
belong so badly but what I got out
eventually was I started to receive
compassion from the people at least
deserved it from when I least deserved
it people that I thought I hated started
to show me empathy and compassion and I
started to humanize them and it was the
first time I had a meaningful
interaction with the people I thought I
hated how old were you then I was 22
when I left the white supremacist
movement in 1995 1995 what I did 1 leave
the white supremacist movement it's
actually really difficult not only for
security issues
you know and fear for your life but also
because when you become a part of this
movement you give up everything that's
important to you and this is the only
identity community and purpose that you
have so leaving that behind and starting
over is often a barrier for most people
to leave a lot of people talk about hate
groups in the rise of hate groups in
America how do you see that today well
there is absolutely a rise in hate
groups but that's not the number that I
go by we see a rise in hate crimes and
and xenophobic activity and that's
really what I go by because I know that
30 years ago we tried to change the
image of the movement we knew that we
were turning away the average American
white racist with our swastika tattoos
and our shaved heads so at that point we
decided we were going to try and
normalize that we were gonna grow our
hair out trade in our boots for suits to
go to college campuses to recruit where
young people may feel marginalized or
developing their their new ID this is
this is white supremacists who are now
taking time into branding that's the
focus absolutely and and they're now
using terms like white nationalists and
all right which I know that they just
sat in a room one day and they said what
can we call ourselves to make ourselves
seem less hateful we used to call
ourselves white separatists to the
public but behind closed doors we you
know we were saluting neo-nazis well is
that fair to call they all right is the
alt-right an extension of that is right
now the alt-right has seen some some
people see it as an extension some
people just see it as an extension of a
political ideology you know it's I think
that that's how they're fooling people
is by by latching on to you know
right-wing politics when in fact there
are there are far-right extremists or
terrorists even in some cases but I do
believe that what we started 30 years
ago led to what we're seeing today with
you know the the repackaging and even
more palatable words that they're using
we used to call it you know the the
global Zionist conspiracy and and now
they're calling it globalism we used to
call it the Jewish media that we thought
controlled everything and now they're
calling it the liberal media well but
not everybody who calls it the liberal
media has a racial identity behind that
no but I think the best people like to
just put people down it's just an easy
slang right
but that's the power of how normalized
the language can get you shut you talk
about you talk about white terrorism yes
now I I listen to our president I listen
to Tucker and I know about terrorism but
I know about Muslim terrorism right are
you just co-opting this idea of Muslim
terrorism for this idea of white
terrorism no actually most people don't
know but since 9/11 more Americans have
been killed on US soil by white
supremacists and by any other foreign or
domestic terrorist group combined there
have been hundreds if not thousands of
murders committed everything from
Charleston to Charlottesville Oak Creek
Wisconsin to Portland and we as a
country for some reason have a hard time
calling a terrorism even though it is
ideologically based even though it is
meant to instill terror in the name of a
political motive and we have yet to call
it terrorism and I think until we do we
won't really understand or will be able
be equipped to deal with this problem of
white terrorism that's growing I I want
to talk I want to talk a little bit
about life after hate this is an idea of
getting people in a similar position as
you and bringing them back to the
mainstream is that fair to say well
helping them find their path back on the
road to life how do you how do you how
do you maneuver a path like that well
first of all I listen and I listen for
what I've already sounds too hard and
it's not easy listening to some some
pretty awful language but I listen
because what I'm trying to identify are
the potholes that they've hit in their
life's journey could be trauma it could
be mental health issues it could be
unemployment or even extreme privilege
and then what I try and do is I try and
fill in those potholes because when
people are more resilient when they're
more when they have more self-esteem
there's less of a need to blame the
other but I don't stop there I do
challenge them ideologically in a non
aggressive way I'll introduce them to
people that they think that they hate
I've spent hours with Holocaust deniers
and Holocaust survivors Islamophobes and
Muslim families and Imams and even
homophobes and and LGBTQ communities
because what happens is they begin to
humanize then instead of the
demonization and the prejudice that's in
their head and in many cases that's the
first time that they've ever had an
interact
with somebody they think that they hate
I want to get your take out our
president I think that our president is
a trump supremacist more than anything
else that he is only worried worried
about what's happening to him and that
he has his own intentions
so is that a bad thing should we all be
like I guess shouldn't I be a Jordan
supremacist shouldn't you be a Christian
supremacist I guess that gets confusing
but that would be that would be a little
confusing I think the President of the
United States has a duty to represent
everybody and to make decisions based on
you know everybody's best interest and
not just his own his new book is called
white American youth my descent into
America's most violent hate movement and
how I got out
Christian peach LED everybody